prime minister was too afraid to stand
up and answer it and debate me the
question was about the cost of the
second carbon tax we know that the prime
minister's first carbon tax will cost
41 cents a liter at a net cost to
average families of over fifteen hundred
dollars but that's not enough for him he
wants a second carbon tax will to add
even more costs without any rebate at
all we know that he told falsehoods
about the first tax will he finally have
the guts to stand up and tell us how
much his second tax will cost Canadians
The Honorable minister of the
environment
thank you Mr Speaker if you'll allow me
I will read from the conservative party
of Canada's election platform from the
last election the platform that this
party stood and spoke to Canadians about
and I I'm quoting from page 78 Mr
Speaker our plan will ensure that all
Canadians do their part okay I'm sorry
I'm starting to hear chatter again I'm
having a hard time hearing the answer
and it's coming from a certain point I'm
sure they don't want the next question
to be swapped with the last one and have
someone very special to them
The Honorable member for Lethbridge
apologized please
apologize to the chair for interrupting
very good thank you now
I want to remind all of you to have some
respect for this chamber
that includes the honorable member for
Timmons James Bay no I don't want to
hear no no no no no I'm not I just want
to say I hear is chattering throughout I
just want to ask him to keep it down and
start please now we'll go back to the
minister from the talk and I want to see
everything calm down the honorable
Minister please
Mr Speaker the leader of the opposition
and many members across have called me
woke before and if woke means standing
up for the future of my children and
grandchildren so that they have access
to clean air and clean water then so be
it Mr Speaker the flow means standing up
to create jobs for generations of
Canadians and investing in clean economy
then Soviet Mr Speaker
standing up for the rights of women to
choose then Soviet Mr Speaker
The Honorable leader of the opposition
[Applause]
he's woke and so Canadians are broke Mr
Speaker
I'll tell you what woke means in
practice his government approved dumping
millions of liters of raw sewage into
the St Lawrence River that's what woke
means woke means charging a single mom
higher cost to drive to work and feed
her kids while the Prime Minister Jets
around using Canadian tax dollars
pumping emissions into our atmosphere
that is the woke hypocrisy across the
way and if he's got the guts to tell the
truth really tell us how much will
carbon tax 2 cost Canadians
The Honorable Minister for families
so it's exceptionally disappointing from
the leader of the opposition is that at
a time when families in Alberta are
experiencing some of the worst wildfires
in their history he's railing against
policies that are helping to fight
climate change Mr Speaker when he talks
about that single mom unfortunately he
has opposed sending her the candidate
child benefit which is what thousands of
dollars in her pocket and he's also
opposed the child care agreements that
are supporting families across this
country save thousands of dollars Mr
Speaker when it comes to the environment
when it comes to supporting families we
know where the we're the leader of the
office the Battle of Vimy Rich United
Canada as a nation to the service and
sacrifice of
3598 Canadian soldiers Terry Fox's
marathon of Hope leaves a legacy that
lives to this very day for our nation
and Nelly McClung pushed our nation
forward with more equality and human
rights as a suffragette leader but
instead of honoring the Great Moments in
our countries history these Liberals are
instead focused on man with wheelbarrow
and squirrel with nuts Mr Speaker why is
this liberal government so intent on
erasing Canadian history from our
passport yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
the conservatives acted when they were
in government they spent more time on
symbols than on action Mr Speaker when
it comes to our veterans what did they
do they closed nine veterans offices
across the country when it came to
cancer what did they do Mr Speaker they
didn't make any
ends what did we do we invest in the
Terry Fox Foundation Mr Speaker when the
Terry foxhound statue is being
desecrated what did they do they cheered
on the conflict and when it comes to Mr
women's rights Madam speaker what are
they doing
they introduced legislation to to make
it harder for a woman's right to choose
give me a break
[Applause]